donc je disais que j'étais encore qu'un
tout petit garçon et il prévoit de la
neige sur toute la région
je m'imaginais déjà joué dans la neige
voir le paysage enneigé et regarder les
gros flocons tomber le lendemain je me
lève
j'ouvre mes volets je suis tellement
content de voir la neige aidé à vous
imaginez bien pluie vent tornade
ma voisine qui s'envole bref imaginez ma
déception
alors pourquoi venir ici vous parlez de
prévisions sur plusieurs mois
alors que certains d'entre vous me dire
on vous n'êtes même pas fichu de prévoir
le temps sur deux jours
si je vous raconte cette anecdote c'est
parce que c'est là que tout a commencé
pour moi c'est là où je me suis
intéressé au monde de la météo
je m'appelle gérer ni sur ça je
travaille au cnrs d'orléans dans un
laboratoire qui a fêté d'ailleurs ses 50
ans cette année
alors lorsque je dis que je suis
passionné et je travaille dans la météo
forcément me pose tout un tas de
questions par exemple va-t-il avoir
suffisamment de neige pour aller skier
cet hiver ou encore il y aura-t-il des
gelées tardives ou même y aura-t-il de
la neige pour noël décaisser des
questions peut-être que certains d'entre
vous se reconnaissent mais il est
impossible à répondre avec une grande
certitude
surtout aujourd'hui 16 novembre si je
suis devant vous aujourd'hui c'est pour
partager un secret qui concerne la
prévision comment on peut prédire la
météo alors pas sur quelques jours mais
sur plusieurs mois
comment fonctionne un modèle qui peut
prédire la météo sur plusieurs mois je
vais vous présenter un modèle de
prévision météorologique que j'ai créée
savez vous quelle est la différence
entre la météorologie et la climatologie
quand on parle de métérologie on parle
de prévisions des conditions
atmosphériques juste au dessus de vos
têtes sur une courte période de quelques
jours tandis que compte quand on parle
de climatologie
on part d'étude du climat de prévision
de quelques mois à plusieurs années
alors revenons à notre modèle il existe
plusieurs types de modèles
nous avons le modèle dynamique qui
repose sur des équations très complexe
al'inverse vous avez le modèle de la
pierre qui lui est très basique comme
vous pouvez le voir quand la pierre est
mouillé ben il pleut quand la pierre est
sèche
il fait beau il fait sec c'est un modèle
qui demande très peu de ressources
informatiques mois ce soir je vais vous
présenter un modèle de prévisions
statistiques alors peut-être que pour
certains d'entre vous la statistique
comme les mathématiques rappelle de
mauvais souvenirs au lycée n'est ce pas
je vais ce soir essayer de vous faire
voir un autre aspect de la statistique
son utilité allez c'est parti concevoir
son propre modèle de prévision
météorologique j'ai envie de dire c'est
comme concevoir sa propre recette de
cuisine
alors pour créer ma recette j'ai eu
besoin de plusieurs ingrédients il y en
a cinq
le premier ingrédient des données issues
d'observation climatique en météorologie
si vous voulez connaître ou savoir le
temps qu'il va faire à un endroit précis
par exemple en france
il vous faut beaucoup d'observation or
sur la france sur l'europe sur les miss
fernand est encore plus loin jusqu'au
soleil
alors pour plus vous aurez de valeur
d'observation meilleur sera votre
statistiques on arrive au deuxième un
gradient qui est beaucoup de variables
mais c'est quoi
ni variable alors une variable peut-être
ça peut être la température la pression
atmosphérique
le taux d'humidité la direction des
vents à votre avis combien at il fallu
deux variables pour prévoir le temps de
notre hiver sur la france combien il
m'en a fallu 182 vous imaginez qu'il
faut beaucoup d'informations pour
réaliser une prévision donc à ce stade
vous avez d'un côté les valeurs issues
d'observation et de l'autre les
variables tout va bien rajoutons une
pincée de statistiques encore la
statistique est utilisée dans de
nombreux domaines par exemple en
économie au management marketing
mesdames pendant la période de soldes
quand vous recevez vous êtes sollicité
par mail pour un vêtement en particulier
c'est la faute des statistiques pour
nous également messieurs en métrologie
on utilise la statistique par exemple
pour répondre à cette question un
événement une vague de froid s'est
produit une première fois à une période
de l'année
pourquoi pas une deuxième fois allons
encore plus loin
les résultats de la statistique vont
permettre de mettre en évidence si si il
a un lien entre des phénomènes
climatiques alors une succession de
sécheresse des canicules d hiver froid
des hivers plus doux avec le
réchauffement climatique y at il un lien
entre ces phénomènes et le réchauffement
climatique seront ils plus fréquents
plus intense ou est ce tout simplement
ces clics
de nombreuses études ont montré que les
inondations qu'il a eue annie
souvenez-vous en septembre 2014 n'avait
pas forcément un lien avec le
réchauffement climatique
y at il vraiment un lien entre le
réchauffement climatique et ce et ses
inondations comme à chambord qui a eu en
mai 2016 on peut pas le prouver que le
réchauffement climatique soit le
responsable
revenons sur nice si vous prenez une
carte des sols de 1950 et nos cartes et
des sols de 2010 vous allez voir que la
différence est là l'urbanisation
l'urbanisation est un problème majeur
qu'on retrouve sur toute la planète
si vous changez la nature des sols vous
changer l'état de l'atmosphère
prenons un seul couvert de végétaux et
un autre couvert de béton vous allez
voir que la température n'est pas du
tout la même
et imaginez qu'un orage passe par là
vous allez voir qu'il n'aura pas du tout
la même intensité
voilà pour la statistique donc nous
avons vu le premier ingrédient des
données issues d'observation le deuxième
des variables maintenant que nous
faut-il un troisième ingrédient
effectivement les trois ingrédients qui
est un passionné
l'ingrédient le plus important un
passionné qui va savoir établir
regrouper établir des liens statistique
entre ces variables trouver des liens
alors ça c'est la partie la plus drôle
était celle que je préfère traiter
toutes ces données et voir laquelle 20
avec laquelle c'est génial
je vous raconte cela de façon assez
simple mais ça m'a pris quand même
plusieurs années
passons aux petites anecdotes encore
j'ai mon correspondant canadien avec qui
je suis en contact il m'a fait je lui ai
je vais transmis les données et les a
regardés et il m'a dit il fait mais
quand il fait froid au québec
il fait souvent froid au il fait souvent
d'où en france je vais vous montrer
nous avons une courbe qui représente 1
température moyenne que l'on a en france
tous les points qui sont en dessous de
zéro ce sont globalement des hivers
coincé froid sur la france et vous
l'aurez compris tous les points
au-dessus de zéro qui sont des divers
corps était plutôt doux la deuxième
poule c la température moyenne comme
observe au québec
vous voyez que globalement ses courbes
sont opposées l'une à l'autre
alors nous allons essayer de mettre en
évidence un lien statistique entre les
hivers que nous avons au québec et les
hivers que nous avons en france
maintenant la question mon correspondant
at il raison et ben oui il a raison
globalement globalement quand il fait
froid au québec
il fait souvent d'où en france passons
au quatrième un gradient qu'ils aient
trouvé la bonne formule mathématique
encore des maths
il faut en essayer plusieurs une formule
mathématique c'est un algorithme qui a
été déterminé de manière statistique
alors pour alimenter cet algorithme il
nous faut des données d'entrée et s'est
donné d'entrée sont par exemple des
situations climatiques que l'on observe
sur l'hémisphère nord pendant notre
hiver regardons ça
par exemple il fait plutôt froid et sec
au canada c'est plutôt venteux humide et
pluvieux hand sur l'atlantique plutôt
doux et calme sur l'europe du nord froid
et neigeux en europe centrale est plutôt
froid et sec en sibérie statistiquement
quelle sera la prévision pour la france
en hiver un existait un exemple eh ben
ça sera plutôt un hiver très doux qu'on
aurait mais surtout très sec
vous voyez quand même qu'on peut
s'amuser un peu avec les statistiques
passons au cinquième un gradient et le
dernier qui est déterminé l'erreur c'est
plutôt amer mais c'est quoi une erreur
une erreur par exemple je veux raconter
une petite anecdote une anecdote un ami
avec qui je prends souvent le train me
dit jérémy nous avait prévu de la pluie
ce week-end et nous avons eu que
quelques gouttes
peut-on considérer cela comme une erreur
pour faire simple oui c'est une erreur
alors dans ce type de situation je vous
le dis honnêtement pour vous vous ne
verrez strictement pas la différence car
qui pleuvent que ce soit humide que le
cese soit couvert gris ou quelques
gouttes
ça changera pas la couleur de votre
week-end il ne fait pas beau par contre
si je vous prévoit du soleil et nous
avons de la pluie je pense que certains
d'entre vous m'en vouloir
alors à la suite de ces cinq ingrédients
laisser reposer effectué quelques
simulations
ça veut dire que j'ai testé mon modèle
sur des valeurs passées sur des
événements qui se sont déjà produits
pour vérifier sa fiabilité sa cohérence
et sa pertinence
maintenant vous avez compris comment
j'ai conçu mon modèle grâce à ces cinq
ingrédients qui pour vous vous montre
comment on peut prévoir des sécheresses
des périodes de pollution en hiver des
canicules mais sur plusieurs mois al
avance vous souvenez des cinq
ingrédients nous avons le premier
ingrédient nous avons des données aussi
d'observation y en a qui suivent
puis nous avons sélectionné des
variables statistiquement nous avons
notre passionné qui intervient qui va
établir des liens statistiques on a
déterminé une formule mathématique et
évaluer l'erreur puis effectuer quelques
simulations voilà alors ce travail qui
je l'espère pourra aider apporter des
réponses dans certains secteurs comme
l'environnement par exemple
l'agriculteur sera quand arrosée caen
planté ce qui entraînera une diminution
des ressources au niveau de l'eau et de
l'utilisation des produits chimiques
dans le dans le contexte du
réchauffement climatique il est
indispensable de connaître notre météo
qui régit notre climat
donc des phénomènes climatiques régit
notre climat
ce modèle dont cette compréhension fine
que permettre à mon modèle sera un outil
un dispositif qui sera j'ai envie de
dire indispensable au niveau de la
recherche fondamentale et appliquée pour
comprendre ces fameux phénomène
climatique
concernant la prévision de notre hiver
peut-être pas le droit à l'erreur
eh ben c'est un modèle pour le moment
qui do plus humide et vous savez les
mois de novembre qui sont très neigeux
en montagne plutôt froid en plein come
on a actuellement sont souvent précédés
d'hivers plus doux
la neige pourrait être en manque en
montagne d'ailleurs en mois de janvier
et février
et si la prévision s'avère être exact
alors le risque significatif au niveau
des gelées tardives sera beaucoup plus
significatif pour finir j'aimerais vous
faire une confidence
vous voyez aussi fou que cela puisse
paraître pour certains d'entre vous
prévoir la météo sur plusieurs mois
pour moi c'est un défi c'est ce qui
régit ma vie et surtout ce qui m'apporte
énormément de bonheur je vous remercie
de votre attention
[Applaudissements]